red sox starting pitcher that is nick
pavetta his red sox debut
and he does he drops into beauty to
phantom one away a little sly johnson
inside corner pair of shoes
nicely done two walks in the inning
runners at first and second with two
down for dj stewart
ball on a strike
breaking ball looped into center field
base hit
that'll get a run home
and the birds take a one-nothing lead as
austin hayes comes around and now the
one-two to severino
and strikes him out side retired but a
run in now the orioles will send out the
left-hander keegan aiken
making his seventh appearance in his
fifth start one and one on the year with
a 3.38
era
up and in for the strikeout
there you go the zoom ball at 93 miles
an hour
fastball perfectly placed at the knees
strike three
got him to chase pitch into the dirt to
strike him out
and he has fanned three pavetta spins
and pitches strike three called at the
knees
93 mile per hour fastball
tried to get him to go and he offered at
it for strike three so he strikes out
four
so the red sox have the first two men on
bobby at 262
16 for 61 as a major leaguer
nobody out to aboard he's going to rip
that one headed for the wall
on a couple of bounces it'll get there
vasquez into third
and he will score the run with jackie
bradley
heading on down to third base and an rbi
for dalbeck red sox could be building a
big inning here
chavis will flare that one to center
field that'll be caught by mullins here
comes jackie bradley jr he will scamper
home and the red sox take the lead on
the sacrifice by chavis it is two to one
alex verdugo had a base hit to lead off
the first
start of the night hitting 328.
he's going to pop that one up slicing
over to drop the ball is stewart and
another run is in to score red sox get a
gift
now what should have been the final out
of the inning stewart mishandled it wow
wow that is brutal that's tough to do
right there drop back and that ball just
you know saying catch me all the way out
to the glove
just clanked it that's all you can say
it happens
got him at the knees
that'll get bobby dahl back to the plate
callback doubled in his first at bat
and a base hit
that's going to chase in another run
boguards will score
jackie bradley jr to third well he's
making good contact tonight two for two
the payoff pitch
is in there strike three lifted up the
arms stewart thought it was inside but
that hard sinker broke over the inside
corner two on days with nobody out
and austin hayes is coming up next
there's that high fastball
swing and a miss and he puts him away
that's strikeout number eight
chopped up the middle should be two
bogarts arrows and on to first to
dolbeck
double play ends the innings here's
michael chavis
with the bases full
bounce down to third to second for one
on to first double play and the orioles
get out of it
and he is struck out
oh that's it well
way back and see you later up in the
light tower
touch them all
man
renato
nunez
a big ball right here looks like a
little back up cutter stays on the inner
third and it gets pulverized
so the orioles have got a man at third
base rio ruiz comes to the place looking
at a line driving in the left shave is
back jumps up this is over his head and
one hops the monster speeding towards
second base rio ruiz he is in on a slide
and the orioles have made it a one run
ball game two men on and two men out for
jd
line drive and that is going to drop
down toward the alley cut off by hayes
araus will score
xander bogarts down to third base and
it's an rbi for jd martinez to make it
5-3 here's christian vasquez who reached
out of throwing here by the third
baseman ruiz
and there's a drive to left field this
is high and dave back by the wall
stewart looks up and this ball is gone
into the monster seats three run homer
christian vasquez and the red sox now
lead it eight to three
alaska's got a low fastball
on the inner half and he turned on it
he's going to line that shot
off the green right back for stewart
he wants second base the throw is the
tag and he is safe he got in there
tagged by alberto is probably too high
getting him at the waist you can hear
that
how about that yeah
putting the throw in the hand in there
well red sox trying to put the finishing
touches on a victory here tonight
illincoby coming out of the bullpens
left it up for ball four
yes
you do
bases loaded
the call to barnes
fastball and a high pop up that should
do it dalby can foul ground he clinches
that and the red sox win it they take
game one against the orioles here
tonight
eight to three the final score